from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Costco food and the US and the
UK this is food Wars
here is an iconic Costco hot dog in the
UK ah yes the famous Costco hot dog in
the UK the length of a hot dog is
eight inches don't laugh
eight inches almost exactly eight inch
dug it's also advertised as a quarter
pounder hot dog let's see if that's true
so with the bun and some onions the
whole thing weighs 250 grams I'm going
to take the sausage out and wear that on
its own to see if that is a quarter
pounder turns out that without the bun
and the toppings it does weigh exactly a
quarter of a pound that's pretty
impressive I know it's like manufactured
and mass made by machines but you know
still cool
oh my God it's exactly four ounces
wow they kept it a quarter pound after
it's cooked and everything see Costco
it's not impossible all these people
watch just know like it's about a
quarter of pound before you cook it well
they said four ounces whatever they're
doing after it's cooked it is the
advertised four ounces way to go Costco
in the UK a Costco pizza is
17 inches in diameter that makes the
surface area 227 square inches in the US
our Costco pizza should also be 18
inches in diameter let's measure it more
like 17 and a half Costco it's still
9.99 that's a ridiculous deal you can
keep that half an inch
our pizza today was cut into six pieces
I'd say for a pizza of this size it's
kind of uncommon to see only six slices
I would expect maybe eight or ten like a
dominoes but we're gonna weigh one slice
and find out how big it is now let's
weigh one slice
that is a dense slice of pizza there's
some citation needed but this might be
the heaviest slice of pizza we've ever
weighed on food Wars
that's a big layer of cheese not a ton
of tomato sauce I would say it's like
maybe 70 bread so I don't know if you're
getting a ton of value for money when it
comes to toppings
quite like it it's got that nostalgic
cheap frozen pizza quality the chicken
bake
I don't know what the origin of this is
but it's pretty good idea it's like a
giant chicken hot pocket right
the guy holding up the fish face just
caught we've already used this gag in a
recent episode but we can reuse it
oh why this is so good this is so good I
will say I love stodgy food
so I feel like I am the target audience
for all of these Foods the fountain
drinks in the UK come in one size and
it's supposedly 22 fluid ounces of
course we have to check it
so in what seems to be an increasingly
rare occurrence on food Wars that is
actually as much drink as we were
promised that's 22 ounces but
our 20 fluid ounces
look at it's exactly 20 ounces and I
filled it up at the thing now Costco is
like razor sharp with the portions right
they're not leaving anything the chance
thank you Costco
here are all the Costco menu items in
the UK that you won't find in the US
the US you won't find in the UK quick
disclaimer that the menu seem to vary
slightly depending on where you are in
the UK or the US I got these from the
chingford location just outside of
London and Joe's got his from the
Burbank location in California we have
one exclusive Pizza option in the UK
from Costco and it's this one the
barbecue chicken pizza as the name
suggests it's a barbecue chicken pizza
which also comes with some green bell
peppers and some red onion when I see a
barbecue Pizza in the UK I usually
Grimace because it tends to mean that
the sauce is barbecue and I don't like
that but I think here they've actually
just kept the same like cheese and
tomato base but out of the barbecue
toppings on top which in my opinion is
what a barbecue Pizza should be
Leon does not agree it still feels
pretty hefty maybe not quite as dense or
as Hefty as the cheese pizza did the
dough seems to be not quite as thick
place with the chicken on its own first
it's not bad I'm not getting much
barbecue flavor from that
it's more just like a sort of grilled
chicken
usually my biggest complaint of barbecue
pizzas is a two barbecue whereas this
one actually isn't very barbecued at all
that means that I like it but if you do
normally like quite a strong barbecue
sauce flavor from your pizzas this one
might not be enough for you in the UK
you can also get whole pizzas as part of
a family bundle the bundles come with a
full-size Pizza one of these gigantic
garlic breads
two of these garlic and herb dips
and also a two liter bottle of Pepsi Max
half of which I have spilled on the
floor of the studio Twisted churro we
got these you guys don't that's not a
lot of stuff all right this thing churro
cinnamon dough
next up we've got Costco's take on a
classic British dish
cottage pie now our American viewers may
have heard of shepherd's pie cottage pie
is basically the same thing in that it's
a layer of some cheese on top usually
some mashed potato but instead of the
Lamb mince mixture cottage pie contains
beef mince now this is a classic British
dish and we do feel pretty passionately
about things like this so let's hope
Costco have done it justice the strategy
seems to be sell large quantities of
food
but really pack it with the kind of
cheap stuff so for example there's like
a small amount of cheese on top here a
very small amount of beef on the bottom
and I'd say like 80 of this is It's just
mashed potato let's give it a try
it's actually quite tasty
it's I'm not
I don't work for Costco I just I'm a
truth Seeker again the beef is like it's
very rich it's quite thick
but there's a real like meaty flavor to
that is it the best cottage pie you've
ever had no probably not but is it like
an affordable filling version that's
fairly true to to the original
I'd have to kind of say yeah you do get
100 more filling as you go into the
middle as well it wasn't all like that
thankfully
yeah I don't know I actually don't think
they've done too bad a job here next up
we have this one which is the double
chicken fillet sandwich considering the
theme of just like Hefty Foods this
thing is absolutely massive
look at it yeah I think maybe they were
supposed to stack the chicken patties
instead of play them side by side
because the bun barely covers any of it
they've also only put one slice of
cheese on it so only about 40 of it is
covered in cheese I might have to do
some quick tactical rearrangement here
oh there's maybe oh there's another bit
of cheese on the bottom so you get
cheese
but then it's like can you eat this
because that is also a logistical
nightmare to eat I think whichever way
you stack this it's going to be quite
tricky to eat but this is the double
chicken fillet sandwich there are two
chicken fillets two slices of cheese
some lettuce and some tomato
extremely dry
very Bland like none of the components
Taste of anything somehow it's a bit of
a miss again it's like it's big
it would fill you up next up we have the
Korean barbecue beef bake so it's like
the chicken bacon that it's kind of a
baguette with some cheese on top filled
with meat but instead of chicken and
bacon this one has Korean barbecued beef
I imagine it's going to be a similar
level of stodginess to the chicken bake
and also to everything else that we've
eaten today the filling on its own
doesn't really taste of much which is
slightly disappointing
that's Bland that's disappointing I'm
still eating it but it's planned
just like nothing that jumps out to me
as like you know Korean flavors in this
if you're going to make something that
bland I think don't drag your ear
through the mud just call it a beef bake
and be done with it there's one other
classic British dish on the UK Costco
menu which Unfortunately they forgot to
give me today and it's jacket potatoes
there's a note in the script where Joe
says that he doesn't know what a jacket
potato is so I'll do my best to just
explain it to you now as the name
suggests it's basically just a potato
that you keep in your jacket in case you
get hungry these can either be boiled or
baked you'll usually wrap it in some
foil just so that it doesn't kind of
touch anything else that's in your
pockets keep it on you and then whenever
you get hungry during the day you have a
nice snack with you as the name suggests
it's basically a potato that you keep in
your jacket
we also have two exclusive dessert style
options in the UK including a caramel
fudge sundae and a Coffee caramel frappe
I didn't get either of them today but
here's what they look like
two
cold drinks
you get here in the U.S Costco is the
fruit smoothie
oh my God that's great
um
well that's really good
and the cold brew mocha freeze
homeboy has melted I'm really surprised
how good these cold drinks are man the
food is good but these are really good
um
yeah that's picking me up that's picking
me up Yules let's go
ah now I need to
calm down a little bit
and finally in the UK we also have mango
smoothies on the menu although today
that machine was broken they weren't
serving them here's what they look like
I want to take this moment to talk about
Kirkland Costco's signature brand that
provides a wide variety of products for
a low cost over the years the brand has
developed a royal fan base among Costco
members it would be impossible to
feature all the Kirkland food and
beverage items exclusive to the US not
in the UK and believe me I begged
management to let me sample Kirkland's
many alcohol options to which they said
no way
so here are a few non-alcohol Kirkland
Signature favorite exclusives in the US
I'm going to start here animal crackers
I mean come on UK and who doesn't love
animal crackers are animal crackers
popular in the United Kingdom come on
guys let's do let's do the animal review
I think monkey a gorilla
orangutan this looks like a hippo
we got hippo oh this is most certainly a
koala I've seen that guy already we're
already getting repeats alligator I
think possibly a dragon
a Brookfield Zoo all on your fingertips
here on crack reform fantastic in the
U.S is not playing with their cheese
selection so many and the one according
to Internet that just everyone is raving
about is of course the parmigiano
rigiano
regiano
one and a half pounds how much do you
think a one and a half pound block of
parmigiano Reggiano costs go
what do you think
actually it was 16 geez both of you I
thought we were like everyone's gonna be
like fifty dollars no 16 that's still
really good 16 bucks for all this I mean
this is gonna last man this will last
many of your uh wine and cheese parties
uh and of course Costco has a fantastic
selection of wine all of which I'm not
allowed to go near apparently according
to management
all right give this video a lot more
entertaining we were doing the wine
review peanut butter peanut butter
peanut butter when I went to the UK I'm
not kidding you every person I talk to
when they realized I was an American
which was literally one second after I
opened my mouth they all asked me the
same thing what is with Americans and
peanut butter is peanut butter not
popular in the UK they were like you
guys you guys put peanut butter and
everything they kind of do
this is really good peanut butter please
forgive me all the peanut butter heads
watching do you want it this liquidy
because I'm thinking peanut butter
sandwiches peanut butter and jelly
peanut butter and honey
whatever you're mixing the peanut butter
with right you want some thickness to it
to stay on the bread do we want thin
peanut butter I don't know I'm asking
you as a viewer what is the preferred
viscosity of peanut butter I mean this
is creamy
but I mean like
cream creamy Italian sparkling mineral
water with carbonation added if anyone
was wondering just how boring I am
my favorite sparkling water is actually
the
non-flavored right like Lacroix my
favorite ones the plain that's right you
better ugh I just like I like the
bubbles in the water
hmm
smells Italian
[Music]
oh yeah it's like really harsh this is
very good
like I want that harshness of the
bubbles
what are you illing about speaking of
Italy
pesto so the basil is important but I
don't think this was made in Italy basil
people swear by this stuff they swear by
it
dried mango slices this right here look
how many of these they gave me man this
is two and a half pounds
dried organic mango slices I am a mango
boy
that's an impressive list of stuff we
don't have that many coconut exclusives
in the UK but there is one interesting
one I found which is this hazelnut
spread this is just Costco's version of
Nutella not Nutella well that was
interesting because I was looking at the
ingredients of this and the percentages
kind of pique my interest so of Interest
we Google what the contents of real
Nutella and the ingredients said that
there were 13 real hazelnuts in there as
well as 7.4 fat reduced cocoa powder so
if we compare it to this one
Leon how much do you think how much
hazelnut do you think is in this
13 percent what to say exactly the same
fat reduced cocoa powder 7.4 so on paper
this has basically identical ingredients
to real Nutella and it smells and looks
a lot like Nutella
I would struggle to tell this apart from
realnessella in a blind taste test and
it is cheaper so hey
next time you're around and you really
really love and tell her you can buy it
in bulk here and you won't really know I
also found some products which weren't
Kirkland brown but did pique my interest
I found this kind of catering sized tub
of Marmite which I could not resist I
assume this is an exclusive and not
something that you'd find in the US not
100 sure made Marmite pasta and put it
on Instagram yesterday and people got
upset so
it felt relevant then I also found some
American products at Costco that you
wouldn't normally see on British shelves
for example Skippy brand peanut butter
this isn't bad but like
so much oil in here you can see it's
like running off the top and it's kind
of made the whole thing go very liquidy
according to the ingredients this is 10
hydrogenated palm oil
which might go somewhere to explaining
why it's so liquidy at room temperature
these caught my eye while I was browsing
the shelves Smuckers Goober neither of
those are real words first of all
but this is peanut butter and grape
jelly stripes is this what Americans are
putting in PB and J's they claims to be
America's favorite combination peanut
butter and jelly how much competition do
they have in this field I'd love to know
Americans love grape flavor things and
it's really not common in the UK for
whatever reason it's quite pretty I'd
love to see the machine that puts us
into the jar in that pattern
this is a lot more solid I think they've
added like gelling agents and stuff to
this to keep it in that uniform shape
with the cool color pattern the grape
jelly is extremely sweet and the peanut
butter even I think on its own is quite
sweet compared to the Skippy as well I
want to give a disclaimer this is the
exclusive sections I don't think these
are exclusive I just know now one
awesome thing about the Costco here in
the US I don't know if it's in the UK
Harry can confirm this is they have
ridiculously good baked goods Costco's
in the US is also famous for having a
sheet cake couldn't get it you got to
order it ahead of time I'm sorry let's
get a picture of that on the screen
with my face on it
but they have so many muffins and
croissants and other things I heard
really good things about the bakery
section at Costco so I also had to give
that a try this goes out to katya's Dad
our producer Katya apparently her dad
really loves Costco croissant I thought
these would benefit significantly from
being heated up it's not bad the star
was like pre-packaged
and finally these cookies get chocolate
chip
double chocolate and white chocolate
in the UK a lot of our like pre-packaged
cookies for whatever reason tend to be
really solid and you can like Snap them
rather than chew them but this is the
much softer American style cookie which
is really good full disclosure this is
the first time I've ever shopped at a
Costco and it's not a snap thing see I
grew up my dad worked for a grocery
chain and then I move out into the world
and the thought of having a case of
toilet paper or a bottled water in my
shoebox apartment was crazy also sixty
dollars for a membership I mean I was
just scraping by so come with sixty
dollars to go grocery shopping was
Madness for me so and then just never um
never went until now for this video and
I think Costco is really awesome I like
it now shout out to Kirkland Costco in
the UK is a little bit weird because not
just anyone can actually walk into a
Costco you have to actually apply for
warehouse membership which is different
to just standard online membership and
to do that you have to be working in a
certain number of limited professions
some of the professions make sense uh
it's things like teachers who may be
working School to buy suppliers and some
of them are really random things like
Airline workers are allowed in I think I
was technically allowed in as a
journalist so this is journalism if
anyone asks I believe a year of standard
individual membership cost around 30
pounds maybe slightly more there's
different tiers as well you can get like
executive membership where you unlock
certain perks honestly I don't really
know why it's set up exactly this way in
the UK I guess they want to kind of have
some control over the foot traffic in
the stores they don't want everybody
just piling into the store I went at
11AM on a Tuesday and it was really busy
and I asked someone on the till and they
said that that wasn't even busy by their
standards I think this is what it's like
in the US but the shop itself was just
basically an enormous Warehouse with
stuff everywhere it wasn't organized
hugely well the aisles weren't
particularly sort of labeled there were
numbers on the RS but didn't say what
was in them so I just kind of had to
like snake around and try and find what
I could find things were slightly
cheaper in there than usual but I don't
even think things were like massively
discounted particularly the Branded
stuff compared to the Kirkland stuff so
I think you're more just going because
you need to buy things in bulk and it's
like be more convenient rather than
because you're trying to save a lot of
money on your day-to-day groceries for
me to be able to sign up for this they
needed to see a pay slip so they could
prove who I was employed by kind of
weird
foreign pizza from a UK Costco will cost
you 9 pounds 99 which at the time of
recording was 12.38 a Costco Pizza in
the US is 9.95 or 8 pounds three Pence
that's a 19.9 price decrease in the US
the Costco hot dog here in the U.S with
a 20 ounce soda is one dollar and fifty
cents the same price it's been since
1985. how has Costco managed to sell
them for so low for all these years in
an hyc meeting everything has been hit
by inflation the Costco hot dog has
become somewhat of a viral phenomenon
their commitment to keeping the hot dog
combo at 1.50 is so strong that as The
Story Goes when the current CEO
approached the old CEO about possibly
raising the price he said if you raise
the price of the hot dog I will kill you
figure it out and they did Costco would
soon switch from selling Hebrew national
hot dogs in their food courts to
manufacturing their own they open a hot
dog Factory in La then in Chicago
reducing production costs and keeping
the hot dog at the dollar fifty price
point today it is fair to point out that
our hot dog costs one pound fifty which
is more like 1.86 it does come with two
more ounces of soda so maybe that's why
or maybe Costco just likes the aesthetic
of having 150 on the site
a slice of pepperoni pizza from a UK
Costco is 826 calories while a slice of
cheese pizza is 751. the most calorific
thing on the menu is a whole pepperoni
pizza a whole pepperoni pizza is
4962 calories which is 248 of your daily
allowance a slice of pepperoni at Costco
in the US is 650 calories a slice of
cheese roughly the same size would be
710 calories that's 60 calories more hmm
does that make sense that the cheese is
more calories than the pepperoni I got
it
wow the UK chicken bake is 911 calories
an entire U.S chicken bake is 840
calories
a UK hot dog is 602 calories the hot dog
and 20 ounce soda in the U.S is 582 850
calories depending on the drink you get
so least calories would be of course a
Diet Pepsi which has zero calories if
you got a regular Pepsi that'd be 250
calories and if you want to get the most
calories in your drink that of course
would be 280 extra calories if you've
got the Tropicana fruit punch animal
crackers I mean come on UK
these things
this is this is a Twist off right it's
like I'm breaking into a vault come on
just